[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
uh i don't know i just thought of
something funny i get confused on which
guest is
going to be this week and we started
doing an intro and
realized ryan looks at me and says wrong
guest
wrong guest it's funny how different
guests
act in terms of people are busy i'm not
it's just funny how some people are
really incredibly professional and on
time and this
i think most people strive to do that
to be that um i know i do um
but sometimes things happen well
things get a little crazy sometimes and
uh
this uh this guest was it was a lot of
fun it was one of those things where
he actually messaged me a few weeks ago
and was like
yeah i might uh yeah i'd love to come on
the show again
if you need a guest it's just really
cool i [ __ ]
freaking i don't want to f-bomb but and
um
it was funny because i was like yeah man
of course i'd love to have you
you got a new show you're doing things
you're a funny guy you're a big comedian
and so i see you know i was like great
how about this date
you know 10 30. and then a week before
he's like
hey are we doing this right i'm like
yeah yeah yeah 10 30 next week
10 30. up great
and uh so uh then we get to the day and
i'm sitting here with
ryan and i'm like i don't know if it's
going to happen i mean
you know again when you're busy you
don't if you don't write things if i
don't write something down ryan in my
calendar if i don't
write it on the whiteboard if it's white
it if
if it's if i text myself forget it
because you know the texts keep going
down as people text you and you it's
gone
if you email it i have a better chance
of remembering and then writing it down
and putting in the calendar
i'm a one-man squad sort of here at the
house so it gets
i lose [ __ ] so i understand so
all of a sudden 15 minutes pass and uh
i i call him i actually didn't have his
number but
one of my friends gave me it but i had
his email i mean you know we're buds
and uh and he's like he calls me he's
like am i
like yeah how you doing he's like this
is now
i'm like yeah yeah we're going to do the
yeah all right you know i just woke up
and uh
let's jump in the shower you know clean
off
and uh give you a call it was great
it wasn't ultimately really that late he
wasn't you know he was just you know
he's just so funny he's naturally i
always say there's certain people that
you look at
and you're like he's just funny i think
i say that to him in the beginning of
the interview you do yeah
i found myself laughing a lot i don't
laugh a ton
right he had some good stories he has
some good stories jim jeffries and
you're right it's the accent and it's
just his general appearance
and everybody yeah and everybody always
wants to do the australian accent the
english accent we're americans we can't
always do it he's like hey
but uh i went to australia a few times
and we talked about that but uh
just want to say thank you to everybody
out there who's listening i do it every
week but the the patrons uh you're
unbelievable thank you for joining
patreon thanks for uh giving extra
support to the podcast and uh
again if you don't know what patreon is
join it go to the inside of you podcast
on patreon and
there's tears and you get questions with
me
and you get to ask guest questions and
you get
youtube lives and discounts on merch on
the online store and conversations with
me
and it's a lot of fun man it's a big
community it's
it's people are just really loving it
it's a family you can see in my
room on the couch where ryan's sitting
we got uh insidey pillows that
kristen uh made for me and leah and look
at this pillow over here inside of you
look at with all the names of guests
it's pretty incredible i got you know
this is um look at this this is
emily made me this and you know i have
these things i keep them you know uh i
think they're really nice when people
make me things it just makes me happy
and
you know like i'm a fan i have posters
and uh anyway we know all these things
uh this saturday
coming uh the 29th of august
rob danson and i will be playing another
stage at our monthly stage
we just do one and uh we got some new
covers that are awesome we got some
originals that you haven't heard play
some left and laurel songs there's some
zoom calls for winners top
bitter prizes all that shite it's gonna
be a lot of fun
and um anyway it's it's so funny because
right now i'm texting with doula
name drop dulay hill and james roday
and uh james roday rodriguez
sorry changed his name back to his
surname original surname which is
amazing and um but they're coming on the
podcast so
uh thanks for all the support i love you
guys it means a ton to me
um we're gonna just keep on uh keep on
rocking
great news coming up coming soon i can't
wait to express that with you
but please follow us on all the uh
social media
on instagram at insideepodcast um at
insideyoupod on twitter and
um write a review all that stuff
email your friends tell everybody just
want to keep growing this thing and just
want to keep being real and open to
guests
i feel like you know somebody said
you're like uh someone you're like a
listener you
you ask questions that people will
would want to ask and
he's like you kind of dumb it down i'm
like what is that what does that mean
that's like candid yeah he's like no no
no you're just you say things like
like a kid wants to know like you're
just curious and i go okay i like that
that's kind of how i feel i just kind of
want to you know anyway
all right so thank you right now this
guest he's uh he
sells out all over the world sells out
sells out uh
stadiums all over the world big comedian
you've seen him on everything
uh he's working on a new tv show that's
gonna be coming out he's got a new
podcast to talk about
um he's awesome he's hilarious let's get
inside of jim jeffries
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you know i know why you're successful i
know why you have all these shows and
all these
you stand up around the world because
you just look at you and you just
there's something
i don't know like your next special
should be called
innocent looking but [ __ ] up
you just look like you're such a like
you had this gentle
face like the this sweet look on your
face but you're up to [ __ ] no good
jim i know it
i'm like a cabbage patch doll
you mean a garbage pail kid yeah i'm a
garage dog whatever happened to them
let's reminisce about that and all the
stuff that went on how are you my friend
anyway enjoying quarantine
i'm making the most of it man i've been
in and out of uh
in and out of uh sort of anxiousness you
know
anxiety a little little depression but
mostly you know good
the busier i am man the busier i am is
that is that how you're doing
you're busy yeah i you know you go up
and down
i i i either like doing a lot of work or
no work
so this sort of middle ground is isn't
good for me
because you know it's not it's it's
still people saying i
turn in this or write this script or do
something like that
and so you still have you still have
that feeling of anxiety where you've got
homework
looming over you you know you know it
doesn't feel like a holiday
you know did you do homework as a and
when you were young were you always the
guy who
like i was honestly i'm not just trying
to say i was the guy who tried to get
out of it
i was the guy who tried to cheat i was
the guy who was like
you know the smart kid be friends with
that guy uh i would always try to get by
because i never thought i was very smart
or that i could do it on my own
yeah i um i didn't i've never studied or
anything like that i've never been that
like
who you put the time in you know i i
wish i
i wish i could tell you that i was a
more conscientious person but i was
bloody hopeless i was
and uh i'm gonna try this charger
all right i reckon i'm good now can you
still see me is that your screening room
yeah yeah that's you know i thought i
had a cool screening room and it's just
a couch and a big screen but that's
that's the real deal that's like
somebody came in there from amc
and did your [ __ ] first of all you know
because it's funny because you
communicate through instagram
that's sort of how in a lot of ways i
mean you're like hey man hey mate this
is easier for me just like you know
you know i'll do the podcast mate so is
that a bad australian accent
yeah what time i'm like uh all right 10
30.
great uh you want the day yeah sure
just like and then so right before you
come on
my editor here ryan my engineer and he's
like he knows to come on right he's
gonna you know
i don't know i don't know where jim
jeffries is
like look i don't know you that well
i've never really hung out with you i'd
love to hang out with you it worries me
that
i'm it's unpredictable i usually you
know those days of hanging out with
people who go get you know
shit-faced and all that i don't know
exactly if you do that but there's that
maybe preconceived
thought am i gonna get in trouble if i'm
with jim or is jim going to just like
nah mike we're just going to go for a
burger uh
i think there's there's a myth about me
that you're going to get wasted and
there's going to be drugs involved and
all that type of stuff
and that myth is was perpetuated by me
i put that all out there so so when i
when i get like
when i start working on a for a new
network or something like that and they
they really talk to me like you know you
gotta behave right and i'm actually a
pretty well-behaved bike
who's done something most of my party
was done in my twenties you know
we were forties now and and so so i i
you know i've only got myself to blame
but yes that could happen
we could get [ __ ] faced but probably
we'll be fine
probably so i wouldn't be in any danger
most likely oh no i never get arrested
or anything like that you're all
fine it's very very safe again my main
advice these days
is i like an edible every now and again
and i i
enjoy i enjoy magic mushrooms
and i do them about once every two weeks
and that's not really a shit-faced
scenario is it that's a
i've met a lot of in fact women who you
know you get on a dating app or whatever
and you know you kind of you don't want
to interrogate but you want to find out
you know is this a party person
is this a whatever and then they're like
you know it always comes down to
well i like the edibles i i'll have a
mushroom every once in a while like you
know every other day
but uh i mean i i had a bad experience
on mushrooms and i never did it again
but i'm wondering if i should because a
lot of people say it could be fantastic
it's a wonderful it's wonderful i don't
do hard drugs i haven't done hard drugs
in a very very long time
and uh i'm glad about that because they
used to be so depressed the next day and
alcohol makes me so depressed the next
day
and mushrooms i have no depression on
afterwards none
and so that for me is i'm really i'm
really thinking about tomorrow more than
the experience in the moment i guess
but like i it's one of these things with
mushrooms you can have
you can take them for eight hours and
you'll have seven hours that are
wonderful
and then there's about 15 minutes in
there that where you just go
oh i never did anything with my life i
could have been a better son
oh god i should apologize to this person
i [ __ ] over when i was 18.
you know what i mean like those things
come and haunt you but you never do that
you never in the middle of mushrooms go
i'm going to call
you know sally and well i always i
always speak to a friend of mine and
that
they'll always go you're fine you're
worrying about nothing everything's good
you're not a terrible person you know
i'm not and then you know the next day
they go you are a terrible person but we
felt like in that moment
that's exactly right well see here's the
thing you know when your friends are
like oh man try this joint here just
take a hit it's really good to go
no no because then you take a hit off
that joint and you're looking in the
mirror going you're fine
you're fine so i don't trust those guys
anymore so i have to get the right
amount so
if someone goes hey just try mushrooms
now mushrooms might be right that amount
might be perfect for jim jeffries
but i take it it might put me over the
edge i'm a lightweight
so how do i know like little amounts
little amounts little amounts until you
hit
your ceiling you know what i mean that's
why the whole wheat thing like
remember the wild west of marijuana when
people made
edibles and you'd have a brownie and
you'd have no idea
how much was in it and you're just like
all right off we go and now you get
these little blueberries and they say
five milligrams and you're like okay and
then it'll take ten
will you take 20. i always take 20 is my
sort of
entry level i take 20 milligrams then
sit back
and then i just eat like an [ __ ] you
know then that's it
have you gained any weight in quarantine
no i think i probably you know
i mean i'm not i don't i'm not bragging
about it but the only thing i've done is
like
i'm trying to work out every other day
but i started i got stressed because my
dog is a little sick and it's
he's old and it's like all these things
start coming at you and you're alone
i'm alone a lot but i you know i started
smoking a little bit cigarettes
not good no not good and i'm not doing
it a lot but it's not good you you smoke
no say i don't touch it yeah i don't do
anything else really but i'm like
why are you do i'm sitting there i'm not
even enjoying this cigarette i'm like
why are you doing this
yeah yeah i know that's the worst of all
the habits that one oh my god
i wish i never touched one of those
things you smoked for a long time
i have i have done but i don't need
longer don't touch him
i had a doctor tell me once he's like
you smoke i go oh well you know maybe i
don't know maybe a pack
two packs tops a week he's like oh
that's nothing that's that's not gonna
bother you i'm like really
like why did he tell me that why did he
say that was okay
you know those ones where you answer the
doctor this is the problem with the
american health care service they go
how many cigarettes do you have a week
how many drinks do you have and then
you're like
you and you go well i should answer this
honestly because this could save my life
but i don't want to answer honestly
because it might make my premiums go up
and i you know when i when i get my
final acting job i'll never be able to
get health care because i was honest
so i'll just risk cancer and tell a lie
right now do you have any back problems
no
michael you have seven back surgeries
you put no here i'm like
yeah but i don't have back problems now
i i once when i first got to america i
had to get private health care because i
didn't you know i didn't have health
care here i just had to pay for it and i
was like not a citizen and
all that sort of stuff and so i thought
i'll be honest because i i'm pretty
healthy person i've got no
you know main big problems and i said
i've i've had a few hemorrhoids in my
life for one hemorrhoid surgery which
isn't pleasant
and i said uh and i said and i've been
on and off antidepressants
um for about 10 years but i haven't
taken them for the last four years you
know
but i suffered from depression and then
they came back and they were like
you have to pay like 600 bucks a month
for health care and i was like you're
[ __ ] what
because i've never been a country that
didn't have
public health care you know and so so i
was like why and they said
ah because you suffer from depression
and i go
but the end result is i kill myself and
you don't have to pay for that
it's not like it's not like it's not
like i've got an ailment that's going to
keep getting worse i'll have to be put
into traction and all this type of stuff
it's like
there's only two ways this can go i
didn't get better at work
i didn't know that when you fill those
little questionnaires out that's for
insurance
i'll tell you what when i had the
hemorrhoid surgery right they put me on
a
on a triangle uh like foam
pillow this big triangle thing so your
ass is right in the air
and then they they put it they put they
they they shave your [ __ ]
and uh they give you the gas that you're
about to be knocked out the anesthesia
right
and just it's one of those times that
you don't want to be recognized
right and just just as i'm i'm going
down this is i'm about to go into that
sleep
one of the nurses sticks and my head's
in like a massage chair hole
you know like i'm going forward and
and uh this nurse she ducks her head
underneath and she looks at me and she
goes
my boyfriend's your biggest and then i
fall asleep
and i'm like what are the chances that
that lady
isn't going to go back to her boyfriend
and go
oh we looked up jim jeffrey's [ __ ] it
was filled with poets
[Laughter]
that's exactly what i i would think i
would think that's what oh my god
they're gonna go tell them
what a dirty [ __ ] i have somehow my
[ __ ] my [ __ ] lips are bigger than
anyone else's
yeah like jim jeffries has a huge
prolapsed [ __ ]
that we had to do surgery on and you're
like ah
all right and then you can't sue her
because then any attention's really
well everywhere find that's why i
mentioned things like this on podcasts
it's nice to have
those things just out the open so you
know they're out of the way
yeah do you go to the doctor a lot are
you a guy that goes
you're sort of a hypochondriac you word
you see a mole i see a mole like on my
leg i'm like oh that's weird
that wasn't there before no i like i
don't think i overly go i go a few times
a year to the doctor i try to get a
physical and that type of stuff but
my my mother used to go to the doctor
every week every week she had a standing
appointment with the doctor she'd go
every thursday
even if she had nothing wrong with her
she was just like she was like a rusty
old car that they kept on tinkering with
and just kept it on the road and she
would go in
you know and and so i i think
i think because of that i
i purpose purposely make myself not a
hypochondriac
right and go you don't want to live your
life like that constantly worrying so
maybe i don't worry enough about my
health
you know my mother did that too but my
mother even to this day
it's like she's going she's like someone
just died
she's like i'm getting my mama grandma
michael i i'm just so scared
just will you pray for me i'm just
really like mom and i got
for years i would kind of you know
consult her and go hey you know it's
going to be great your boobs
your breasts they're going to be
everything's going to be fine
you know and then now i'm like mom [ __ ]
off
we do this every time the one time i
yell at her it's [ __ ] something
horrible is going to happen but she's
always hypochondriac so i think i
developed some of that
and now i'm backtracking i'm sort of
like hey i went to the dentist once this
year that's enough
i'm brushing my teeth i'm going to the
doctor i'm going to get a prostate exam
i got my first prostate exam at 48
probably should have got a little
earlier
you know i didn't like it once a year
man or or
whatever i'm not doing i'm not i'm not
going to do it i'm not going to go with
the doctor all the time
my mother used to go every christmas
she used to she is my mother has passed
away but like before she passed away
every christmas she went she went this
will be our last
christmas together we had about 10 years
of this
i don't think i'll be around
for the next christmas okay
and then like maybe 15 years ago i got a
phone call at the edinburgh festival
and i get a phone call from my dad
saying your mum's not well and then
mom mum was there saying that she she
may not make it through the night
i had the family doctor say oh no she
might not
make it through the night you know and
uh
uh i was like oh no and so i i cancelled
all my shows
and i got the plane and i flew for 24
hours
and not knowing because you couldn't
turn your phone on not knowing what was
going to happen
i flew from 24 hours from london to
sydney stopping off in hong kong
and then i got there and i rushed from
the from the airport into a cab and i
get the hospital
she's sitting upright on the ipad all
right
there's nothing wrong with her there's
nothing
[Laughter]
the the doctor goes to he goes our
spirits really picked up when she heard
you were coming
so when when she when she was dying when
she was dying
and uh i was here in america when that
happened they bring me up going oh she's
got about 48 hours and i went are you
sure
it's a long flight because i've done
this before
did you give her grief when you saw her
when she was alive or you're like oh
yeah there was definitely i definitely
said next time you better be bloody dead
do i set an economy for 24 hours
oh did she get upset with your humor i
mean because you talked about your
family you talked openly about stuff did
she ever say
i didn't do that she was i mean we
talked about in the last time you were
here a long time ago but
i mean because she she was so loving and
amazing but then she could be violent
right yeah my my mother my mother uh
the best thing she ever did the best
thing she ever did for me
uh is she never complained about any
jokes i made about her
it was it was unbelievable because she
was such a strict parent and then
you know especially having especially
having
a comic like me as your son it could be
a stressful thing
you know someone who talks about you
know
like having sex with women taking drugs
and then tells
nasty stories about their child and that
type of stuff it can't be fun for a
parent to watch
do you think her friends like imagine
like she was just with her friends
you're not around
and one of her friends is like what's
her name what was her name carolyn carol
she's like
carolyn it's like is is he right about
that
is it true is it true like would she
scarf like no
no i've had family members who have
stopped talking
to my parents for not not for a long
amount of time but you know six months
or whatever stop talking
because this dumb [ __ ] that i said on
stage
and she never said anything about it
like this is the reason i don't hang out
with caroline
oh yeah yeah no no there's a few people
like you should be ashamed of your sons
like
i told a story about my grandmother i
told a story about my grandmother and
one of my uncles were very upset about
it what was it what was it
i'm not gonna tell it because the
family's back together if i tell it
again
if i tell it again i'll get more trouble
that was like a big sticking point
the story was only partly true you know
i embellished it for stage purposes and
then oh
god the fallout from that oh come on i'm
not joe rogan
it's not like a million people are going
to listen to it
yeah you're not joe rogan none of us are
he he's he's the biggest man in uh
he's he's got to be bigger than howard
stern now right oh yeah i mean look he
he's done it forever people think oh you
know what this guy
this guy's been busting his ass for
years man with the stand up with the
wwe with all that [ __ ] the podcast for
you know now all of a sudden the
the pandemic i'm glad i was pre-pandemic
i was doing this podcast
before any of this hit and all of a
sudden the pandemic hitting every
[ __ ] actor out there
i got a po i'm looking at people like
you have a podcast
you have a billion dollars you don't
what are you doing
well i i which brings me to i started a
podcast in the fandom
i know i know but yeah but you but
listen you've also had
talk shows you've had i've had a few
podcasts right
this one's called i don't know about
that and it's about it's not
guest related we have guests on
specialists and what we do is we
we pick a subject every episode and then
i say everything i know about it i don't
know about the subject before we go in
i say everything i know about this
particular subject and then
the the guy that the the expert will
correct me on what i've got wrong
it's basically what life was like before
the internet when you're in a bar and
you met someone and they just told you
things and you had to believe that they
were telling the truth
i love it and i watched it and if
they're not telling the truth you just
go i don't know about that and you walk
away
you know i saw i saw one with jay leno
it was hilarious because you were like
i don't know a lot about cars or
whatever and you're like you know so how
many cars you have i was obviously
uh 190 100
do you drive them every uh do you drive
them all each one every
a year and he's like yeah you're like
you're a liar there's not enough days in
the year for you to drive all these cars
and you guys started going it was
[ __ ]
yeah hilarious was james was a good
sport he that's the problem with podcast
days like jay leno
rang me up to congratulate me on my on
my oh
god now on my special
he said i just hey i just watched you
specialize really i can't do the
impersonation
right and and then you you do that thing
that's the problem with podcasting you
can lose a lot of friends because
it's like being a person who sells amway
products
you know what i mean it's like it's like
it's like uh hey why are you there do
you want to do my podcast you're just
bothering people all the time yeah part
of the reason why i just wanted to have
professors so that i didn't have to
bother comedians
with asking them all the time i would
come on if i'm big enough if you want me
to come on i'd come on anytime come on
well i what would be your specialty
i don't know i'd think about it heart
what smallville would you do smuggle is
that big enough
is that my specialty smallville yeah
that's what you know more about then
well i know a lot about horror movies
ah horror babies there you go is that
boring though is that boring talk that's
a good one
that's a good one horror movies uh 80s
music
80s cheesy rocks 70s light rock 80s
you like music from the 80s 70s and 80s
but i
i'll go one further i go like i mean
i'll listen to some air supply i'll
listen to some glenn fry you know
are you gonna stay with the one who
loves you
i'm a 60s and 90s all right 90s too i
love the 90s i like a little 90s cheese
come on i'm
edie brickell yeah i'm uh okay i like i
like your nirvana
and your and your oasis and uh i like
i found it the other day i was i was
reading something do you know that
that canada only discovered that they
had diamonds
in the 1990s that's the most canadian
thing ever
like in the 1990s they didn't know until
they
like they're one of the biggest diamond
producers in the world right
they found it i was watching a
documentary and they found out the 1990s
that they had that means that like when
they found diamonds
in the background wonderwall could have
been get out of me
like oh look they just ban this sparkly
rock i better get home and find out
what's happened with ross and rachel
but even even more so
if they discovered diamonds a lot
earlier maybe the dollar
the us dollar wouldn't be double of what
theirs is
maybe even or they'd be jesus the 90s
that that's good i like that i'm also
the opinion with music
i don't want any more music i don't i
don't want any more new stuff coming in
i agree with you i've got enough songs i
don't need any more songs
once you know the lyrics for about 2 000
songs that's you done
you don't need any more songs everybody
just needs 2 000 songs they like and
that's all the music that anyone should
ever watch
you know we are [ __ ] parents because
i honestly almost can't name five
songs from 1999 to now
i couldn't name and i'm not kidding like
i'm not saying there's not some good
songs
but the 60s 70s 80s 90s
maybe a little at least you could
differentiate you could say
boom this is where we are this way it
feels like everybody's got a beard and
tight pants now and
uh top hats and it's like the the amish
are making music i love the amish
they're not gonna listen they're not
gonna bother
the last new band i got into the last
new band
that i bought albums for is the killers
and when was that that was about 2005.
all right
yeah that was the last new band i really
got into maybe 2000
maybe 2000 around then yeah now is the
music just worse is honestly or are we
just
the same thing as our parents were i'm
just sitting away i'm just an old man
who's just like your bloody kids with
your loud rock and roll and just stupid
things
you know i'm i'm the equivalent of like
our grandparents
when the beatles came out just listening
to frank sinatra going what is this
garbage it sounds like noise
it's loud what do you honestly what what
you know because i honestly when i'm in
the car i'll listen to
ambrosia 10cc the hollies
chicago to just chill me out where other
people need loud i need something that's
calming what do you listen to
i listen to the beatles and crowded
house in my car
dude i love crowded house i love crowded
house what was that song what was the
one song that i loved
what's the one song that you loved well
the one song it was their big song it
was kind of a love song
what the hey now yeah
[Music]
that was a big song there is freedom
within
the ariana grande and your miley cyrus
did a duet of that
and i remember like like liking it and
then going oh
oh nobody nobody better know about this
i had to listen to it in private my car
i wouldn't turn it on when someone else
because i got a tesla it has a channel
so i had an aria
grande and miley cyrus channel and i was
like oh god how do you delete this thing
i had to put in other channels to make
it go to the bottom of the list
you seem like someone who wouldn't care
about what people thought and that's
what you do ah
you know you gotta there's some some
things i have my limits
fiona grande that's your limit i gotta
no one can see this
my brother uh went and saw uh uh taylor
swift in concert a couple of times i
like her
with his daughter and then i think he
secretly became a fan because he went so
many times with his daughters
these things can sneak up on you when
you're like oh no i like this
music now uh you know what i'm i'm not
taking back what i said but i think that
if we probably gave
some things a chance we we might like
them of course we would but it's also
it's like
i i don't need it though i've got enough
songs i'm sure 2 000.
there has to be good music coming out
but it's like
what's the what's the point of it and
also the songs don't
all music is related to happier times in
your life
right so when you're young and you're
out and you're trying to meet
girls in nightclubs and stuff like that
that song resonated and when you
graduated college that was the music but
all the parties that you listen
to and when you you know i mean i don't
have any big events anymore
i don't want to remember any of this i
don't need songs
dude i sort of got jim i i i
i i i know it's layman's terms and it
seems very simple to what he's just said
but it's it it just hit me that's
exactly
what it is if i think of uh metallica's
black album
i think i'm on the third at 13th street
living with my buddies
in a little [ __ ] we're paying 100
bucks we're having a keg party we're
charging everybody three dollars for
milwaukee's best
and we're gonna make enough money to go
to murray's the next morning to have a
grilled cheese sandwich
and my friend takes my roommate takes
the black album out
and goes i go what are you doing man
people are enjoying this we already
listened to it i go
put it back in put the metallica back
and he's got i got he's got a he's got a
cup of beer
and i've got a pitcher and he looks at
me and he's just like no we're not
[ __ ] playing any metallica people are
tired of here and i go
the party's just starting it's a new
album play play it
and i just he just throws a [ __ ] beer
in my face i'm like
you [ __ ] and i throw a pitcher
of beer in his face he didn't know i had
a picture
and my i mean we're just standing there
we've never raised our voices with each
other and we're about to fight each
other and my other roommate comes up and
goes
what the [ __ ] are you doing you're
friends
it's metallica and then we put the
metallica back in for one more play of
the whole album and that was it but i
remember
certain you're right certain moments in
my life where happiness and like
true by spandab ballet playing at emil
camacho's house and we're dancing and
and now i think about like music i'm
like well i'm sort of depressed
anxious i don't know what's happening
we're in a pandemic i don't want to
remember this song no you don't want to
remember this song and nobody nobody
hears it you know like when even when
you have it like a kid
the music the modern music of the time
isn't that you're always playing them
songs that you know so you can sing to
them and stuff like that
i feel like everything stops when you
have a child as well so when when you
when you become a parent you don't buy
new clothes anymore
you just that's the outfit you're
wearing that's the day it stops
like my my father still wears a baby
blue pair of
shorts that have pockets on the front of
them and they have a belt buckle
where the belt's also blue i wear shorts
and a t-shirt every day i have no class
ah
quarantine i mean underwear are you an
underwear right now
i'm just sitting in underwear and a
t-shirt in my in my screening room
holding me holding me phone because my
computer wi-fi wasn't working properly i
had a whole thing set up
inside of you is brought to you by
better help online
counseling don't fast forward uh we all
need this
especially during these times and um i
mean all the time i mean people get
anxious
all the time they get depressed this is
human nature anybody that you know
that's like
never gets depressed never gets a you
show me someone let me see that person i
don't believe it we're all human
and uh so if you're struggling with any
of that right now you're obviously not
alone
so don't believe it if someone tells you
or if you're feeling that way
better help offers online licensed
professional counselors who are trained
to listen
and help counselors specialize in all
the diverse areas which i
i said depression and anxiety grief
uh relationship conflicts and much more
all you do is fill out a questionnaire
to help assess your specific needs
you get matched with a counselor in
under 48 hours
talk with your counselor in a safe
private online environment at your
convenience from wherever you're
comfortable
easily schedule secure video or phone
sessions with your therapist plus
exchange unlimited messages
that's what i do i do that
everything you share is confidential and
that's the beauty of it all so don't
feel weird don't feel like
someone's going to judge you no one's
going to judge you everybody's going
through this if for any reason you're
unhappy with your counselor you can
request a new one at any time no
additional charge
join the million plus people taking
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced
better help professional with so many
people using betterhelp they're
currently recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states
betterhelp is an affordable option and
our listeners get 10
off your first month with the discount
code inside
get started today at betterhelp.com
slash inside that's betterhelp.com
i-n-s-i-d-e
you've done you have how many we have
four specials on netflix now you've had
four
four specials on netflix i had one
special on hbo one that was on show
time one that was on epics
and one that i independently made
um so i got i got eight specials all up
jesus christ and you have and you have
another show that develop developing
called jeffries is that still in
development
well it got put on hold we were we were
one week out from filming we with the
sets were built
and the casper's cast and i i
this just shows the the the lack of
power of the human brain
i i was it was a multi-game sitcom so i
i
learned the script like i was like just
reading it every day like i want to be
prepared i don't want to show up and be
an idiot because
you know also that thing being a
comedian and working with someone like
you
who's a real actor we always get very
like
oh we don't want to look stupid you know
i know i can be funny on film
but i don't want to seem unprofessional
so and i don't really know what the
protocol is so i try to over
study you know what i'm about to do and
and
so i was practicing and practicing
practicing and reading it every night
and then
like about a week ago i was like huh
maybe the show will get you know the
show isn't canceled it might happen
tomorrow it might happen in six months
or whatever so
i went oh maybe i should uh practice
some of the lines
you know couldn't remember one of them
all gone have to start from scratch
i did that back in february and now my
brain just went oh we don't need that
information just flicked it out
that's why it's like what is the point
of going to college and studying for
four years you don't remember anything
no one remembers any every everyone only
remembers enough stuff for the exam
and then they do it and then it's over
it doesn't look like
like a doctor isn't going oh i remember
in second year of med school and a third
lesson what to do here
it's trial and error could you do me a
scene from smallville right now could
you remember
oh [ __ ] no no no way now the only thing
i could do is because fans asked me to
say this can you say i am the villain of
the story
and i go i am the villain of the story
thank you i was watching uh
the office the other day and and dwight
quite smallville
oh yeah he did lex luther or something
right yeah yeah yeah he said that yeah
he was on the podcast i loved him he was
awesome he's very
the office has become my um
my my show i have on in the background
when i'm doing things i think i think i
watch it
every day yeah it's a great show i
watched that in cheers every day they
took cheers away
this is the problem with me i'm getting
like i'm getting about my tv shows the
same way i have about my music
i don't need new tv shows i know all the
good ones
i've got cheers i've got all in the
family i'll tell you how you know you're
going old
the channels that i watch on tv
advertise
negative mortgages and life alert
necklaces all day to me
i must be a [ __ ] old man they're like
all the adverts i watch go have you
fallen and can't get up
and i'm like oh no sorry it's my
grandmother trying to call me
maybe she's falling and she can't get up
that could if that would not be that
wouldn't be funny i was gonna say funny
that would be funny a coincidence a
coincidence and i'd remember this moment
and it uh you know when you're talking
about memorizing lines and stuff do you
get sort of anxious when you learn lines
because you did like you've done shows
you had your own show legit which people
loved and it got canceled but like
you know i know i remember it bummed you
out but you you studied musical theater
you've done things it's like
yeah i um i legit i was really proud of
legit
and i i uh
i would have liked to done i that's the
only that's the that's the thing in my
career
out of everything like the jim jeffries
show got cancelled that was fine
and i you know i've had other setbacks
and stuff like that but that's the only
thing that i still
feel a little bit pissy about is the
cancellation legit because
it was moved to fxx which and then they
were like oh the ratings aren't great
and you're like
yeah you moved us to fxx and it's up in
the sports channel
and we had no lead-in and we had nothing
after me a lead-in
was repeats of mad about you right like
what the [ __ ] was meant to happen right
and so i feel like that show has gained
an audience since it was cancelled
it i get people write to me every day
saying they like that show and i really
would have liked to have
finished off that storyline and every
now and again i think about like
making a little movie or something just
to to wrap it all up do it
do it listen now listen you love doing
it you love a story it's personal story
it's a it's characters you know
characters you grew up with
a disabled friend in it it's original
and it's dark and it's and all the and i
think if you love something it's like
how much would it cost if you shot
another 10 episodes yourself
i'll i'll i'll [ __ ] do it yeah that's
true i could shoot it myself and put it
on youtube or something yeah
the problem is if i leave it too long we
have a character
that's terminally ill he should be dead
by now
not not in in the fictional world yeah
yeah that's true
you're picking up right where you left
off and maybe looks older but people get
it
well no another idea i mean thing
because you know if you listen to those
podcasts that are like the scrubs one
and the office ones where they go over
each episode
i was thinking of doing one of those
legit i don't care if
only a hundred people listen to the
podcast if as long as those people are
enjoying it you know what i mean like
i was thinking again me damn backward
role and dj calls and
and doing each episode of legit and then
if it was popular enough
my plan is because i i wrote half the
scripts already for season three that
never happened
i still have him right and so i was
thinking of doing a radio play
to wrap up some of the storylines you
should
yeah why not yeah you do it with like a
like a sound effect guy like oh the door
frame
like an old world the worlds what was it
back in the day when they did that radio
show was it world that wore the world
war of the world's awesome worlds the
war of the worlds
people thought it was an actual news
broadcast right now
because we've had dummy since the dawn
of time
it's not just now you know when you put
something on the internet you go look at
this idiot and it's like no they've
always been around idiots
hey do you how often do you go on stage
unprepared
yeah so what what happens is i i
quite often about once for about three
months
every two years i go out
after i bring out a special i go i
i retire all that material and then i
i'm starting fresh and i have a vague
idea of what i might
do but the material isn't embedded in my
head yet
and so i go out knowing that i have to
talk for an hour and a half
and i think i have about five minutes of
conversation i just hope for the best
and it's like it's very it's very
nerve-wracking because you could be
playing in front of thousands of people
and you're like all right i'm gonna give
it a go and i never write anything down
i've never written a joke down so i have
no
logbook of what i've done so some people
put like a little
set list on the floor or something so
they can go and check it
and and so i so before before quarantine
happened i just
had a new show and i'd done it about 10
times and i
was really liking it because i recorded
the special and i was ready to go
and i tried it out in clubs and i got it
up and running
same thing now it's been so long i don't
know what that set was
i know that i talked a long time about
the australian bushfires
and that was a lot it feels like a
lifetime ago but that was
february australia was on fire do you
remember that yeah
wow yeah i remember i donated i remember
it being horrifying and now you don't
even think of that it so
it feels like it's years ago yeah it
feels like that's who worries about that
we lost like two-thirds of the koalas
unbelievable
uh all right listen this is called [ __ ]
talk and this is all my patrons who
support the podcast they get to ask some
questions so it's rapid fire you just
[ __ ] nail it just go
whatever you want you want to answer it
emily s what's your favorite
place you've traveled for work uh my
favorite place to travel for work is i
look i love london i love i'm going to
london for
gigs i get excited to go to london for
gigs and you know i spent my 20s there
so
i have you know a favorite restaurant i
want to go to and i have friends that i
want to see
and i i go see me soccer team full and
play
and you know so london's probably my
favorite place to travel for work
mike e big fan love your comedy when it
when things are better
do you have any plans to try and do
another show or make the jump into the
big screen
well the problem i i've i've had
opportunities
to have small parts and films you know
i've been offered small parts and films
here and there but
but you know i think people think when
you do a movie
it's you get paid millions of dollars
and and a few people do but
most people don't right and and so
whenever i get offered these jobs
they're always just like it's like it's
next month and it's very hard if you're
a touring comic to cancel all your live
shows to be able to do it so i've never
been able to do it
if i had some spare time and there was a
movie i would do it for peanuts i loved
the experience but i never had the spare
time would you do a horror movie
i'm not a fan of horror movies well of
course i'd do a horror movie yeah all
right when i
when i do i do i i i would like to do a
drama but my problem with dramas is this
is i've done a few dramatic scenes and
they make you really unhappy afterwards
if you have to cry on the screen you're
really sad afterwards and in comedy
they go cut and then everyone starts
laughing well hang on there's different
ways to approach it like
thank god as crazy as i am i was able to
people would joke because i would be
goofing and farting and laughing and
never telling jokes and holding court
and the crew's laughing then we're
rolling
michael we're rolling camera here and
action all of a sudden i'd jump in and
i'd be serious
i couldn't stay serious all the time
i've talked about it but so
i was able to just get in and get out i
couldn't stay into that
i was able to get out of that pretty
easily i couldn't because i would have
just probably died
so you have a tough time do you ever
work with actors who
don't get out of character who do the
voice all day at lunch and all that
stuff i've you know yeah i've had people
where
actors and you and you gotta respect it
but like you know first you start to
think you know what
you know your your ego it's like wait a
minute they don't like me is it me they
don't like me why are they such a are
they being an [ __ ]
i remember john glover who played my
father on the show
great actor one couple tony's worked
with everybody
the pilot episode man he was just very
just like oh okay i'm like [ __ ] i gotta
work with this guy for 10 years or
whatever
and um i was like [ __ ] man i don't think
he likes me and then of course
after the pilot we talked and i'm like i
thought you didn't like me he's like
no i was just really nervous i was just
really in my own
head i was trying to do my so it's never
about you it's you it's always about
everybody's got their own method so if
no one like i like to joke and if it
bothers some other actor
he should probably [ __ ] off and go sit
somewhere or i'll go
away so just this is a respect thing but
i don't know man if i i try i can't stay
sad [ __ ] unless
here's the thing if you have to continue
being sad in other scenes
you don't want to go you're up and like
you want to kind of stay in a moment if
it's if you have to do it again right
away right
i don't know [ __ ] yeah it's teachers
uh acting in the sense that
i i i i liken it probably to being an
athlete where
you don't want the other actors thinking
your [ __ ] or the weak link in the team
and it's like and being a comic i'm
always like oh
god i'm not a trained actor i'm always
i'm way more nervous acting than i am
doing comedy i'm terrified when i go to
do acting
see i and you said that before you
hinted about that dude
and i'm thinking i i
i i do the same when i was doing i
wanted to do stand-up i was like [ __ ]
i've always wanted to stand up people
you know harland and a bunch of my
community nick schwartz and they were
telling me do stand up just do it i'm
like i'm terrified
and i'm more terrified because i'm
i have done i've had success like in
other words i wouldn't be as scared if i
nobody cared or knew me or anything but
to get up on stage with like guys like
you or schwartzen or joe rogan
i'm putting myself with the lions and
i'm like how could i possibly succeed
here
and it was so terrifying that everybody
was like dude [ __ ]
everybody else do your whatever you
think's funny
say it and they may go oh that's [ __ ]
amateur hour
yeah you got to start somewhere just
keep doing your [ __ ] and
it's hard so the i think it was for me
it was important to hear that to go
hey man i'm doing this for me i mean
[ __ ] i'm going to go up there i'm going
to get i'm not going to think about what
they think about me so when you're
acting you can't think oh i'm acting
with some guy who's been acting for 20
years i'm just a comedian i gotta
impress him or i gotta
i think you you got it you went to like
[ __ ] theater school whatever you
you could do the [ __ ] i went to well
i'm really looking forward to hopefully
we make this show jeffrey's i'm really
looking forward to doing
a multicam i think i'll enjoy very much
but first of all i'm playing myself so
that's always easier
right but i i think i'll really enjoy
acting in front of a live studio
audience
if we can because that was the first
that was the first thing they said to us
when the code would happen they said oh
the show's still happening
but there won't be a studio audience and
i was like [ __ ] and i was i remember
like i wasn't arguing but i was like
sort of pleading i was like
well what if we bring in our friends and
they sign a release form and they all
get tested
yeah you know what i mean jim you have a
hundred friends
yeah well exactly all you need is 30
people in there just
to know and one guy who laughs at
anything
well also the thing with the old uh
where the people always go with it like
the multicultural sitcoms they go oh the
canned laughter
it's not ken it's real laughter people
are there watching and laughing it's
real
yeah but sometimes you're like how are
they laughing at that nine times out of
ten i'm like
how is that [ __ ] funny i've been on
sitcoms and when you were like it's the
best all right you know
i'm like sorry if i i don't know why i
jump in like you oh everybody does that
because you have a cool accent somebody
tries to do you so
also when i'm like i'm like nah my shut
the [ __ ] up just do
it to me shut the [ __ ] up so when i was
i've done a couple i did two years on a
sitcom another one year in a sitcom
a pilot two pilots and
i didn't like it i didn't like it
because it always changed up till
thursday and then friday they're
throwing new [ __ ] out you know i'm like
[ __ ] i gotta learn all these things and
i don't know what
and it's it's nerve-wracking like
learning things on the fly i liked in
pasta
i thought that was good thanks it was
fun but it wasn't a sitcom
it wasn't a live audience that wasn't
live audience but it was funny thanks
man
i loved it you know one of those things
is like it went two years and
got good reviews it's like legit right
and then all of a sudden they cancel and
you're like well lasted two years it's
not like i got canceled after a pilot or
one season it made two c so you kind of
just gotta look at the bright side of
things man because you could definitely
go
like [ __ ] what and they were like well
we're skewing towards females i'm like
all right
let it go well i when they when they
canceled the jim jeffery show to begin
with i was like
huh because like my ratings were okay
and it's like
i guess people don't want to watch me on
t i was like a bit down for a couple of
weeks you know
and then and then what happened was then
what happened was like
comedy central basically just fired all
their executives and everything
and now the show that the channel is
basically the daily show
and south park is all they sort of kept
and they got rid of all other shows
right and i was like oh well i won't
take it personally they got rid of
everything
right see that's different they did yeah
they just got rid of us so thanks for
bringing that up
lisa h says what are your thoughts on
the current influx of tick-tockers and
youtubers getting netflix
specials and recognition as comedians
off a short bit being uploaded to social
media
yeah i i try not to be
uh a bitter old man about things like
that like oh these kids today and
they're tick-tocking and they're all
it's not for me i don't get it i don't
get they're just
mouthing along with other there's a lot
of tick-tocks in my stand-up and people
doing my stand-up in their car and you
know
and i don't quite get it but
if if people are watching it if they're
making millions there's got to be
competition right
there's got to be a lot of like with
we're saying all these youtubers these
influencers
they're doing something because millions
of people watch you
and so so you've got to give them credit
and if they're prolific they're bringing
out the clip every week
lots of stuff i don't i don't go on
social media very much for a couple of
reasons
the first reason i don't go on is i i'm
not a big fan of social media
and i i think i'm also a big believer
that
sort of people in the limelight or
whatever there should be a bit of
mystique around you and people should
watch
whatever your art is rather than watch
you
you know that's what i think right and
and
and you know i i find nothing worse than
watching an actor who
who insta story is 20 things long for a
day i just don't like what the [ __ ] are
we doing
right but that's just me but also
there's probably
an amount that i don't want to go on
social media because i don't want to put
myself out there
and put something out that i think is
funny
and then people are like well this isn't
funny you know what i mean so i'd rather
just leave it alone and do my stand-up
and
and so i think it's very ballsy to be a
prolific tick-tocker or youtuber
like there must be some skill there so
just because it's not for me
it doesn't mean that it shouldn't happen
chris f do you think having a child has
changed how you do stand-up
yeah of course it changed out his stand
up in the sense that i talk about him a
lot on stage
um also also i i i am
conscious of um
being as much of a douchebag as i was on
stage because my son might watch it but
then there's the other argument that
all the old stand-up footage already
exists so you know i i assume at one
stage you'll be embarrassed of me he
might be proud of me but he almost also
might be embarrassed of me how old is he
seven have you ever sat down with him
and go look
this is who your dad is i i don't
recommend
some of the doing some of the things
i've done but i'm not gonna lie to you
i'm gonna be very honest with you
or is he just too young to even talk
about that stuff he's too young for that
but i will have that talk
and i i prepare that talk in my head on
a daily basis
will you be sober but you reckon i'm
going to be racking up in front of him
no i didn't dig around i got a belt
around my arm and a spoon
give me a drunk jim jeffries how would
you a drunk jim jeffrey sound
well this is the thing people i know
you're not a drunk now i don't eat you
know a drink you don't people have this
perception because you talk about things
on stage so
i still have the i gave up drinking for
a long time and i still have the
occasional drink now in quarantine very
okay and i don't drink when i work
anymore i don't
drink on stage any longer and i don't
drink if i'm
working on a tv show anymore because i
used to do that whilst i was doing that
and that wasn't good
for me uh now i do it occasionally but
the problem i have
is i think i mumble
um uh naturally anyway i think because
of the accent sometimes i'll do a show
stone over and then afterwards the
review will be like he was drunk as [ __ ]
and you're like no i wasn't i just you
know and i've been
i've been for auditions where where my
representatives have been like he showed
up drunk and i'm like no
it's just i'm just australian
i don't know that's hilarious maybe my
voice has a bit of damage in it from the
past still
maybe all right dude this has been
awesome so what's going on right now
what can people watch what do you want
people to watch what are you looking
forward to
well watch watch my uh my podcast
apart from that my stand-up special
intolerant is now out on netflix
and apart from that uh i you know
i watched the morning show on apple i
enjoyed that
i suggest people watch that that was my
favorite show of the year
nice and you're like you're keeping busy
you're honestly like if
you if you're not busy is is there's a
darkness come out do you feel like
anxious do you get depressed
what i have learned from quarantine is
that i think i'm going to be well
prepared for retirement
i think i'm going to be alright with it
you know a lot of people in the
entertainment industry
they worry that they'll be forgotten and
i think
i wouldn't mind that i think that'll be
okay you know what
if you truly believe that that's
actually a really
good thing to feel and be if you're
honest with yourself because honestly if
you could say
you know i really don't care if people
remember me i really don't care if
i didn't have any impact i really don't
well i i tried me best and i
i i made a i've made a lot of people
laugh and
you know over the years and and if if uh
if it all fades away
i'm used to you know like the thing with
joan rivers
right up until she died was just like if
there's no dates in the diary
you'll be forgotten you'll be forgotten
and i'm like
that must have been a very stressful way
to live she was in her 80s worried she
was going to be forgotten
and it's like just relax and
you know what i mean just if you've made
some money sit back and enjoy it
and what does it matter think about it i
mean when you're gone when we die
it doesn't matter it really doesn't
matter and the people who like you will
like you and they'll get to watch it the
footage will always be there and
you know and uh the people who don't
like you hopefully
they don't spend that much time worrying
about how much they don't like you
i'm amazed by the haters in this world
that put so much energy into hate
it's like is it there's there's bands
and there's comedians and there's things
that i don't like and
what i do is i don't watch them it's so
easy so why get on and harass you if you
don't like you
yeah yeah exactly you know it's like why
are you why are you here you see that
all the time you're like
i hate this music well don't go see them
play in concert at the hollywood bowl
i'm not gonna go see them yeah i don't
know i think people get bored they just
want to hate they want to express
themselves why are you watching a
youtube clip of an
artist you don't like so weird it is
weird
dude i love this man i love having you
on and uh
honestly if you ever need a guest let me
know all right mate thanks for having me
uh another fun episode i hope you guys
enjoyed that
uh if you don't know jim check out his
specials it just makes me laugh i love i
just love that story about
his mother how you know when i was like
the [ __ ] that he would do on stage and
he got he would get himself in trouble
and the family would all be like
well i thought you know what what's this
i just i just think it's so
funny and then like you know uh his mom
wouldn't say anything to him she was
like you know i did this so i'm allowing
you to do this and
i just find it kind of fascinating i go
well tell one of those stories again
no no no no [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] storm
about
he's a lot of fun he uh he got a little
personal the last time
and uh i wouldn't say he's an open book
he likes to joke and laugh but
uh you know trying to get a little
serious
isn't as easy sometimes with certain
people you know but
uh you know i i could tell when we
talked about his uh you know drinking
and i'm like you know obviously you talk
about it on stage and all this stuff you
thought he was a little sensitive
you know i was like well i don't mean
you're you do that now say no
no you know i'm too [ __ ] old i got
all this stuff going on
you know i and i totally buy that i just
i think i thought he was
uh he thought i was insinuating that
you're you're a drunk you're uh i was
like no no i'm not saying that i'm
saying
you know you talk about that you had
this persona and uh
i just don't think he wants to get
offered cocaine on the street anymore
yeah
boy
yeah i've i've had that though we've all
had people come up and say you want some
coke
i don't know oh unless they recognize
you i haven't had one go oh you're lex
luthor you want to do some heroin
uh what no you know what happened
how does that trick uh thanks so much
for uh for listening
guys i really appreciate it and uh if
this is the first time if you just came
here because you're jim jeffries fan
it'd be awesome if you uh subscribe you
know follow the handles at
insideypodcast on instagram and facebook
and at insideipod
on twitter write a review watch the
youtube or on youtube you can watch it
you can
listen to it anywhere so thanks and all
my patrons
thank you so much before i get into the
patrons rob danson and i stage it go to
stageit.com type in rosenbaum and dance
and we're doing two shows this coming
saturday
um the 29th 2 p.m pacific standard time
6 p.m pacific standard time uh covers
uh originals some left on laurel uh
the band i was in before and um it's a
lot of fun they're prizes
zooms you know some people get like we
send dedicate a certain song to you and
we'll we'll text it to you so
we'll play any song you want you just
just go to stage.com
and type in rosenbomb and dance and it's
a lot of fun and we're working on our
album
i guess i should talk about these
wonderful people who
really give to the show and that's the
patrons let's read them out let's read
them out you guys ready for this
so nancy d leah s tricia f sarah v
little lisa yuki go jill e bryant h
lauren g nico p i'm compelled i'm one
like i know these people now so it's
reading their names i want to say more
but then you'd be here for four hours
barry aye angelina g robin s jerry w
emily k bob b
robert b jen almost said jensen ackles
jason w stephen j kristen k amelia o
allison l
tom and jess j lucas am raj
joshua d emily s cjp samantha m
hamza there's certain names you just
remember hamza yukiko
raj you just you know jennifer n stacy b
i think bryce does that purposely just
puts them intermittently throughout the
thing so
it's not all on the road isn't it super
hero too yeah jennifer
hello stacy b carly t jennifer s janelle
b
tabitha 272 not to be confused with
tabitha 273
kimberly e crystal h mike e
marissa n ramirez beth b chris f
chad w leanne p jackie p
rodrigo s rachen ragin
rey a maya p megan d jennifer s maddie s
tiffany i
kendrick f ashley e margie m thomas t
matt w belinda n benjamin r lisa j
kevin v robert s joy w
nicole m amber f james r chris h snow
snow r snow art
noah k and sean v
uh you guys are amazing and i appreciate
it uh also everybody uh go to the online
store
got some new insighty beach towels got
some
mugs autographed mugs new women's v-neck
fitted
t-shirts they're going fast
ryan yeah are you uh you got a good
weekend coming up is there anything fun
i mean just more more the same stuff you
know because we are
in the situation so no do you have
anything fun i know you went golfing
we're like wolf blitzer we're in the
situation we're in this situation room
uh you know uh i do enjoy golfing so i
you know when you're with one person and
you're on the course and
it's just i feel like it's okay i might
have to start because all of my rec
league sports got cancelled like
softball and stuff yeah i can't play
hockey i can't play anything
so i might have to golf or something if
you want to golf take it up man i just
started like a couple weeks ago
and uh i am hitting balls all right guys
we love you thanks for joining us until
next time please keep listening and
watching
subscribing and all that stuff thank you
so much uh thanks for allowing me to be
inside each and every one of you